star yes fist North Star
with that's exactly right what I was
doing as a kid I was doing all the time
with the other kids how do you
successfully learn the grammar
pronunciation vocabulary of Spanish
Russian German English Italian or
Japanese or whatever language you're
learning don't get me wrong I really do
believe that it's important to figure
out how to learn all these moving parts
of the language you're learning but I
also do believe that we should start
with another crucial question and that
question is why are you learning your
foreign language why are you learning
Spanish German Russian whatever language
you're learning I think that finding the
answer to that question finding the real
intrinsic deep reason why you're
learning the language you're learning is
really going to make a huge difference
because if you really know why if you're
really intrinsically motivated then
you're going to learn in the long run
and if you're not you're not going to
see the point after a little bit and
you're going to give up
this question is so critical that I
addressed it first on in the very first
chapter of my book 10 essential rules
for smart language learning this package
contains an ebook an Audi book and also
10 exclusive interviews that I made with
my dear friend and colleague Alex fist
of I know what you're talking about yeah
yes the the Fist of the Northern Star
yes fist of northern star
with that's exactly right that's what I
was doing as a kid I was doing all the
time with the other kids I was like in
the first interview we talk about my
failures especially when it comes to
learning Romanian and Japanese my
passion for Fist of the North Star and
Japanese manga and so much more I hope
you enjoy it and stay until the end
because there's one last language
learning tip that can make or break your
language learning enjoy all right Luca
so chapter one starts off with a major
question and or a statement start with
why start with why now you say this is
actually one of the most critical and
important steps in someone's language
learning and you know I think as fans of
yours we all curious what was your
beginning what is your why for language
learning because as I understand you
were supposed to become and on the path
to becoming an electronic
engineer yeah it all started some 30
years ago uh in the summer of 1990 I
think I was N9 or 10 I I don't remember
exactly but I do remember the fact that
my grandmother was sitting in this Vera
we were like at the summer uh house and
she she was a teacher she was a math
teacher uh in high school uh and then
she said hey look at you want to do some
math do you want to do some French do
you want to do some Latin in this order
and you can't imagine that a 10 nine or
10 year-old kid would actually prefer
spending time on the beach with other uh
kids playing but actually I don't
remember exactly why but I just said hey
um this sounds cool so let's let's give
it a try and I and I started learning
with her I was sitting down every single
day in the afternoon and I was learning
math I was learning French and I was
learning Latin and needless to say I was
completely fascinated by both Latin and
French I I like math as well don't get
me wrong but languages caught my
attention immediately so I think that
might why when people ask me why are you
learning German why are you learning
French why are you learning so many
languages like sometimes you get this
criticism hey it doesn't matter you just
need to speak English or maybe a couple
of languages and you'll do fine um the
reason is is that my family um in
particular my grandmother but also my my
mother and then my father just fostered
this thirst for knowledge I really was
I've always been very curious I always
wanted to know more whether it is
mathematics you know uh languages uh
philosophy astronomy uh and everything
in between so I think that my why um
comes from the fact that I really enjoy
learning sometimes I tell sometimes
people go like hey isn't there anything
uh more fun than
learning I said no I I I love learning
you know okay playing video games
playing soccer uh with my friends you
know and doing other things is great but
I really cherish and love learning and I
think that made a huge difference that's
that's my why my why is the learning the
pleasure of learning in and of itself
and I have to thank my grandmother first
then my mother uh and my father for um
sparking this interest and then
fostering Through The Years so speaking
of which that actually transitions
really well to my next question which is
obviously your grandma seemed like she
was a big proponent of learning were
your grandma your mom and your dad all
aligned with the fact that hey Luca
should become a polyglot what was their
reaction when you decided to go down
this path of the man of many tongues I
have to say that um my father in
particular he in particular he was
pushing me towards this um engineering
um career he he was an engineer and a
mathematician and he really wanted me to
to follow the same path now I don't know
about Serbia or the United States uh you
know because you you have both uh
cultures in you but um in Italy this is
pretty common MH more often than not
parents I think it's it's a mistake but
parents think that their kids are going
to follow their steps you know but not
necessarily and I did ended up attending
lectures at University I got a degree in
electronic
engineering but um at a certain point I
just figured out that that was not for
me mathematics physics um I love it but
at the same time I just wanted to be
someone else I wanted to do something
else in my life and at the beginning of
my my
father he was a little bit disappointed
I would say because again I was you know
he always told me languages are a tool I
still remember to this day kept telling
me languages are a tool not an end in
and of itself true but for me languages
are a tool um I do not live to learn
languages I learn languages to get a
better life to live better to have a
richer life to be able to travel uh in
you know better to get to know cultures
Etc and my ended up accepting it
actually he got very inspired one day he
was listening to this interview on the
radio when I said something like um you
cannot teach languages you can only
learn them by themselves and I remember
I I went back and I I I went to visit my
father and my mother and my father said
uh I really like this passage really
struck me so at the beginning he was he
was disappointed but then he understood
he understood that that was my passion
that's what drives me compels me what
keeps me me moving forward it's like the
love for languages the love for cultures
the love for traveling to get to know
people to get to know the world better
to have a better vision of life and at
the end he was he was one of the biggest
supporters so um I think that really
changed uh with time because he realized
this man that is me is doing what he
loves and I think that's I think that's
the the best thing that can happen to a
person that you end up doing what you
love amazing so your father went from
dis appointment to being extremely proud
of you that's a good turnaround cuz the
twist could have gone the other way you
know you never know we probably have
plenty of those stories great but that's
that's really interesting background to
know um I feel like a lot of our
polyglots are shrouded in mystery so we
don't know about their backgrounds at
all so very nice to hear that um we're
going to transition over to Visions
because starting with why is all about
capturing your vision for your language
and you know in this chapter you claim
that this is an essential step you have
have to sit down and process your vision
you know picture yourself using the
language going through emotions maybe
listening to music in the language Etc
with that being said you have you know
14 going on 15 languages under your belt
so to speak with which language or
languages have you had the clearest
Visions where they just you know
seamlessly came to you I would say that
the first language I learned by myself
German um in that case I really had a
very sharp and Crystal Clear Vision of
how I wanted to learn the language
itself I remember that when I started
learning it and it was 1996 in September
1996 to be precise I was jutting down
stories of myself using the language on
the beach um speaking with my uh
teenager friends um you know using the
language being passionate about the
whole process and it ended up being a
reality like two 2 years later uh
amazingly that's exactly what happened
like I was really thinking wow it would
be amazing to be on a beach and and
singing uh German songs and getting to
know people and you know using slang
with the with teenagers Etc it all
happened so I believe that when people
say well you know dreaming doesn't cost
a think first and for first and foremost
but it can become a reality I I'm a firm
believer um of the fact that we can
share
we can shape our own reality and that's
what happened so for for German I really
had a very Crystal Clear uh idea and
vision but I realized that looking back
you know I've been learning 14 languages
now I speak 14 languages that one of the
main differences one of the the key
factors in learning a language is not
your strategies sure your strategies the
way you learn the techniques the time
you spend with the language they're all
very valuable but I believe that the key
factor especially at the beginning is
your vision is the fact that why are you
learning a language that's so important
and I I believe that one of the problems
that we have as adult Learners is that
at the beginning when we went to school
and we were learning languages be it I
don't know maybe you learned Spanish at
school I don't know that yeah started
Middle School yeah that's pretty common
right in the United States but did you
know did you know did they tell you why
you know that it was kind of an imposed
thing well I'm learning a language
because in the curriculum I have to
learn a foreign language ex that's
exactly what happened to me I was
learning English and and French at
school but nobody told me why you know
nobody in nobody pushed me to get some
inspiration nobody pushed me to do some
exercises like hey imagine yourself
using this language and I believe that
this is an important part of our
training when it comes to learning
language is to First understand why you
want to learn a language I you know we
always say well I always say I've been
learning 15 languages now I speak a
bunch of them but people don't know
about my filers sometimes I failed
learning a language and that because I
did not have a clear vision of where I
wanted to go and what I wanted to do
with a language that made a huge
difference so it's important to have a
vision to know why uh you want to make
this language part of your life and and
transform your life as a consequence of
that great so let's let's dive deeper
into these failures if if you will with
us um obviously you had a lot of success
and as you mentioned this this vision is
something that is just is critical it's
vital um with which language or
languages have you had the biggest
struggles in regards of having a Clear
Vision I would say the first one is
Romanian um in 2010 I tried to learn
Romanian and I didn't have a vision I
didn't have a compelling reason why I
just told myself you know what I want to
add another language to my uh to my
collection of languages and that was a
mistake because I was not passionate
about it I was not passionate about
learning Romanian not because it's not a
beautiful language it is but because I
did not see myself going to the country
and to this day I haven't visited the
country yet I didn't have friends I
didn't see myself using the language I
was just like learning the language is a
pure intellectual activity not an
emotional one I believe that if you want
to learn a language successfully your
the act of learning a language has to be
both emotional and intellectual you know
emotional um the emotional part plays a
huge role nobody talks about it maybe
they started talking about it you know
on the internet but in the school system
we don't talk about emotions we just say
hey you have to learn this way listen
and read and do grammar drills and
whatever but never we never talk about
emotions so the first time that I learn
a language without being passionate
about it I failed I failed after a few
few months I just told myself there's no
point in learning Romanian and um that's
the reason why learning Romanian was
difficult not because the language was
difficult per se but because it didn't
have a compelling reason the second
failure was with
Japanese I believe that one of the
reasons why there's actually two reasons
why I failed learning Japanese first I
did not expect Japanese to be so
difficult when it comes to syntax so
syntax is basically how you form
sentences right we you me you speak
English as a your native language I
speak Italian they have this SV
structure subject verb object I eat an
apple right a simple a simple example
but in Japanese yes in Japanese you have
subject object verb and it's much more
complicated than that but the bottom
line is that the structure the sentence
structure is so different and I approach
it in as I had approached all the other
European languages and it it brought
about major problems uh when it when it
came to learning the language I found it
difficult I found it frustrating I
couldn't speak the language so from a
technical standpoint that was a problem
for me the the wrong approach the the
wrong approach when it comes to learning
the technicalities of the language the
second thing though the second factor
which again played a huge role was that
I did not see myself using Japanese i
Japan is a very very far away country
and it is takes like 13 hours by flight
I don't I don't know but I never I never
told myself you know
I it's not like Hungarian uh Hungary
Serbian Serbia hey couple of hours
flight and you're there just going to be
using the language so that also made a
huge difference these two things like
the emotional the lack of emotional
connection on the one hand and the
difficulty of actually learning a
language so different I had never tried
anything like that before and the
combination of these two just made my um
my attempt at learning Japanese uh uh
you know uh flounder can you say
flounder I'm not sure that's that's fine
that's a word so a mini question if you
will uh for many of us like I would like
to eventually learn Japanese it it would
be on my road map of languages I'd like
to have under my belt as well
um for many of us we turn to Japanese
because of anime right whether we're
going to use the term weeb or weabo or
whatever it is um were you a fan of
anime before you jumped into the
Japanese or were you just like ah it
sounds like a cool language I'll I'll
you know take it on I partially I was a
fan cuz there's uh one cartoon that my
the entire generation an entire
generation of Italian kids watched which
is called H hok noen hok noen we call
that in Italian I don't know if you ever
heard of um hok noen Ken um I think in
English is the the fist star now I don't
remember um I know what you're talking
about uh what is it it not North it's
like fist of I know what you're talking
about yeah yes the the Fist of the
Northern Star yes fist of norn star with
that exactly right that's that's what I
was doing as a kid I was doing all the
time with the other kids I was like
fighting Etc that was like a a pivotal
like um you know cartoon that was was an
amazing cartoon but there were others
because in the in the80s um there was a
a wealth of cartoons and Anime from from
from Japan and so um it was exciting but
I I liked watching them in Italian more
than anything I was not thinking oh that
would be cool to to to watch them in in
Japanese or to read them in Japanese I
bought a couple of books of um you know
uh hon noen or Fist of the northern star
and I have it in Japanese but it was too
difficult to read and I watched some of
them on YouTube but it was not enough
you know to inspire me so much that I
really wanted to learn Japanese and uh
at the time so again so there was an
interest there it just wasn't sufficient
enough to carry out like an entire
Vision to give you that full swing of
emotion needed to you know push through
the tough days and it sound like with
Romanian you just had no real contact
with the culture with the people and so
that isolation eventually led to you
know your um your your even your
confidence I would say in the language
just kind of to evaporate so we have
couple reasons we have the proximity to
a language right like how much contact
we have with it and then you have your
actual connection to it um like what are
you interested in do you have hobbies do
you have friends or not so very nice uh
this came to mind right now like let's
say you were to meet a pretty cool
Romanian person and you got to visit
Romanian do you think you could rekindle
that vision and have another attempt at
it or is it like oneand done you're like
no I tried this there's no more
investment
I used to be a black and white person in
this regard and say well I I I you know
made this attempt it didn't work and
then it's never going to happen but
actually uh I've become more flexible
with age and I believe that if I go to
Romania there's a high chance that after
uh after going back to Italy I will want
to hit the books and learn Romanian
every time I visit a country I get
excited about its culture about its
people it's always been like this no
matter the country I've always thought
oh that would be very cool to go back
and to be speaking the language I've no
notice for example that um for as far as
Poland is concerned or other countries
for that matter the difference between
going there and spending some time in
country speaking or not speaking the
language is huge just like a huge
difference in the perspective you have
the people the way people treat you so
that's the reason why I think no if I go
to Romania and it will happen sooner or
later because again it's around the
corner I think that will rekindle my
desire of learning Romanian for sure it
just goes for any other language
yeah I think you've hit the nail on the
head because you know I've liked Spanish
and it wasn't until we got to travel to
Madrid that I was talking to a security
guard and we were looking for some
building in the center of Madrid that
has like the best view and I'm asking
him I'm like and I completely forgot the
word for building so I just went like
this and he told me oh it's right here
on the corner you know just like take a
right here and I'm like ah okay and then
I asked him he's like edificio and you
know it's just one word One phrase
whatever it might be but it makes that
connection so much stronger and so I was
like yes I'm learning Spanish he
understood
me um so I I completely understand there
all right absolutely so very last
question for this chapter is actually
not a question it's it's a hypothetical
situation we're going to put you on the
spot here Mr polyglot um let's say you
have to come up with a vision right meow
right meow um I'm I'm going to give you
options a b or c but I won't tell you
which languages they are and we're going
to work on one together right now so
tell me which letter do you choose c c
okay well we're gonna
sayaba and we're going to use Arabic so
let's say you had to learn Arabic what
would your vision look like right now if
you had to improvise one um I found
myself in um
Lebanon and I am in a bar at night and
I'm speaking with some friends of mine
and then we're going to take a stroll
near uh near the the sea and it's
exciting because my friends take me to
actually take me to the desert and then
we're we we spend two days there we're
going to talk around the fire you know
those um uh those beautiful images of I
see myself being there and uh enjoying
um not only the weather enjoying a new
feeling because you're in a different
country right and um and they're
teaching me words and we're laughing and
I just realized that all these
stereotypes that we have towards the
Muslim world's uh the Muslim world just
disappear in my mind you know because
when we don't know a world we tend to
think we tend to filter everything
through television and I just realize
step by step Moment by moment uh word
after word that there's a beautiful
world uh behind the the the Arabic
language is not just Modern Standard
Arabic it's Lebanese it's a specific
culture they tell me about for example
their experience with uh in Egypt or in
other Arabic countries we talk about
religion we talk about the differences
between My Religion Christianity and
their religion and through Arabic the
fact that I can actually speak Arabic
opens the world people are nice um that
would be nice to me anyway but but
they're even nicer they realize I can
see the spark in their eyes their
interest that they have uh towards me
because I want to explore their worlds
and then they want to explore mine so
it's a beautiful night I can see the
whole sky and I keep and cherish these
memories of talking to my Lebanese
friends around the fire and I can't I
can't wait to go back and continue
learning Arabic and expand even more wow
shukran Habibi shukran so
very nice well so there you have it it
it really is critical wherever you are
with your language Journey it's never
too late to go back and focus on your
vision focus on the why if that's not
clear you're going to have a lot of
problems pushing through on the tough
days so make sure to start with your why
and get a very clear Vision yes I hope
you like the interview now one last tip
for you grab pen and paper sit down and
for 15 to 30 minutes think about the
real deep intrinsic reason or reasons
why you're learning the language you're
currently learning I promise that is
going to make a difference and once
you've done that just keep it next to
you at all times when you sit down to
learn your foreign language every day if
you want to take things to the next
level please check the uh ebook package
down in the description box and also in
the comment that I've pinned in the
comment section below this video have a
fantastic day and happy language
learning